i didn't want to do it but i did and it
ended up being one of the biggest shifts
for me and when i went to go in there to
say hey
i don't even know what's going on she
just looked at me and said when did you
um lose your self-worth well that's when
you knew you had to grow
and i was like here's the growing girl
i believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and i want to help give you the tools to
make that happen
i'm danica patrick and i'm pretty
intense
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
today we're going to do something a
little bit different
this isn't a deep dive into one person
this is going to be a deep dive into a
word and i'm going to do this with one
of my best friends stacy barnes who
has really kind of been um like my
little spiritual guru along the way
she's always very forward-thinking
open-minded and and and dipping your toe
into
new new mental spaces and new
perspectives
and and always trying to grow so um so
so we're going to dive into the word
grow today
uh speaking of grow and it's my word of
the year in 2019
so we thought that was a really
appropriate word to to go into
so i hope that you enjoy this deep dive
into a word
the word today is growth um growth is
growth is my word of the year as you
well know um
and for me i chose it because
i had been through a lot of things that
felt a lot like that and i thought
man this year when i come up against a
problem
my def my deciding factor is going to be
is it going to help me grow
so that was kind of the intention for
the word intention for the year
was to you know choose things that
helped me grow
because that's the point right like
that's like the point of life i mean
that's what we do
right that's what we do constantly is
like challenge each other
and talk and you know growth is really
the point of
to me it's just the core of life yeah
i totally agree yeah without growth
we'd be stagnant you know and i think
that's not a place that anyone really
wants to be in
but the word also can be very or for me
can be intimidating and at the same time
activating so very courageous word
not surprised that you chose it for your
word of the year
and you know what for me growth
is about expansion and evolution
and to get into those spaces as
you and i have talked about we have to
go inward and we kind of we need to find
their other
there's external ways of growth but
there's also so much from within us that
we need to
i think that's from that's what we do
right that's what that's what our work
is
is like how do we grow so you know
whether it's like i mean for me like
i love watching you know podcasts or
youtube videos
and figuring out ways to go deeper
with my thought processes like i feel
like
the big reason for even this podcast was
action points on how to do it so it's
not even just about like
you know concepts but how the hell do
you do it so
for me it's like right in a journal it's
um you know it's challenging myself it's
finding some comfort in the discomfort
meaning that it's a sign right like the
when you're growing it's going to be
uncomfortable i always tell people it's
like
growing pains there's they're called
growing pains for a reason
and that's because they they don't feel
comfortable like growth is
growth pushes you outside of your
comfort zone and
you know i'm getting better as i get
older at saying yes to those moments
like even something stupid like i don't
like to go in the water
so you know um you know last couple of
years i've been more brave hey
you want to swim to that island no yes
let's go you know the resistance and
within the resistance you use that as
your teacher your
your perspective is different around it
versus feeling
oh no i mean you know that's real that's
a feeling
i'm not wanting to go in the water but
at the same time you're feeling
activated where mm-hmm
but it's my choice i get to choose
bungee jumping
oh yeah like i'm afraid of heights so
for me it's almost
just like to know i can conquer it so go
bungee jumping whatever it is or maybe
it's
maybe like the growth has been um
getting out of thought patterns or like
word patterns things that
so it's like getting out of um like a
thought pattern that i have that's
negative and catching myself and
correcting it so for me
that looks like when i grow from
something that's repeating
over and over in my head i feel like i
feel like i
you first you have to identify it so
first you go okay
that's bad stop judging then correct it
because you can't just like immediately
fix the problem
so correct it with uh well they're doing
they're probably doing their best oh i
don't know anything about them
oh you know say something nice to
correct the situation that you might not
be liking
and then over time once you correct it
enough the correction becomes the
automatic and then
you know the dominant the dominant
thought is the corrected thought as
opposed to the negative one but
it doesn't come without the resistance
or
or another example be social media let's
say you know um
you know deciding when i want to use it
and so you know it might be difficult
when i'm sitting there i'm like getting
my car i'm like
at a stoplight and i have 10 to 90
seconds
to like you know look at my phone and so
you know first when you stop you're like
oh
i pick nope don't pick up your phone and
it feels uncomfortable you're like what
does it matter just pick up your phone
and that's that
little jerk inside you that's like oh
you know just
you know do whatever you want it doesn't
have a consequence but
you know setting certain things to
achieve are
new patterns are hard they just are
they're very yeah they're very hard and
that's why i think growth is
a simple yet powerful word and when you
take it to those levels of using in all
aspects of
our life with how we're communicating
with others
relationships how we communicate with
ourselves
our the stories we tell ourselves
for myself to let go of my own
stories that i have or my own belief
systems
that in order for me to do the inward
work and to heal
i have to be open for growth and it's
almost like going backwards before i can
go
forwards and to really you mean like
identify what it is that is wrong or
like what's the backwards part
well for me and the work that i've done
it's when i feel
triggered i'm extremely sensitive and
emotional
and i used to try and hide that when you
know when i was younger i was teased
about it
and then in my teenage years i i
buried it pretty well i put on a pretty
tough exterior
and as other challenges presented
themselves
in my 20s and 30s with a multitude of
things from career shifts to
challenges in my marriage i found for me
that the triggers that would come
through
so my we're talking about old patterns
right like how we react to something
i felt that they weren't benefiting me i
i certainly wasn't growing from them and
it just they would show themselves in
all different aspects of my life
so relationships career and and they do
right they just kind of show up
they show up everywhere and in order for
me to navigate
you know i had to have some pretty big
shifts to kind of check in and say
what's going on
and i started working with a therapist
and it was
huge for me and so when i say going
backwards for me
my triggers are things that needed to be
healed from when i was younger
and it's not from a victim place but
it's certainly from a place of
going there acknowledging and i wasn't
even aware
of some of them that came through but
then i was reacting in my adulthood
in these actions that weren't serving
myself or anyone around
but i wasn't conscious of it yeah and we
aren't like i feel like when
you know the stuff that happened we were
kids or maybe even the stuff that we
pushed down into the subconscious that
we can't even remember
like who knows how much [ __ ] is down
there that
you you really have like learned how to
cope and not even recognize or think
about and
and can't even remember because it's
been blocked i think our mind is this
powerful abyss of lack of understanding
we just don't understand it well enough
but i do think that that's true
um but yeah i mean and then it and then
just shows up but we don't notice
because it's normal to us
well that's that's where when you're
talking about your patterns and that
you know shifting them and taking having
a different perspective around them
so when for you you feel something
that's just becoming
repetitive and you're feeling like wow
i'm getting
results that that aren't aren't what i'm
looking for they don't feel in alignment
so what is that
and that's where the growth comes in and
you're willing to hold space
when and to have a different perspective
to navigate through it and feel within
because our minds
so much can control how we act
and that's where we hold our memories
that's where we block out our memories
from traumas and things like that
yeah and there's emotional trauma
there's all different types of traumas
that happen
but our minds are a beautiful thing and
they're very
tricky and they can um totally power us
through things but they also can numb
things out
and then that's when we get in those
patterns so to unwire that
and kind of feel into what's coming
through
versus thinking into it for me
has been huge
and that's why i had to go back before i
could go forward and and even back to
look at kind of my old
behaviors or belief systems and you know
that
we were talking about um you know when
we were going to sit down for this
what does growth also take and it takes
vulnerability
yeah yeah because in order to be able to
go there in that state
of openness from your heart space which
is
the most vulnerable space i mean we all
protect that
that's sacred to us and we share that
with the people that we love the most
and we trust the most
so when you're open in that space and
you feel
triggered or activated by certain things
doing that is how are we choosing to
react
from it and sometimes if it's for me
with my sensitivity i can i feel so
deeply
that i can my mind kind of goes into
action
which is my old behaviors it kind of
comes into rescue
versus me just breathing and feeling
and there's a tool that i learned about
five years ago i saw it on super soul
sunday
love it you introduced me to that show
oh it's so good
so it started me on the path of asking
the question what is god not who but
what and that like has led me so far so
yeah thanks girl
yeah you're like my spiritual guru um
so it's called rain and uh
taking that it's a simple little tool
um r-a-i-n and so this just
offers a space to pause so for feel
before we react
what do we i take time and you rain rain
is first
recognized um
a is acknowledge you were sort of
talking about this earlier
yeah so so recognize what is it that i'm
feeling
feeling something about am i feeling
excited am i feeling triggered am i
feeling scared
am i not wanting to open up in that
vulnerable space so we recognize it
then we acknowledge it yeah so okay all
right that's what that is
then i is investigate so how does that
feel for me and what's coming up
is there old belief systems coming in
are there old stories wrapped around it
and n is one of my favorites and it's
non-personal
um that's hard i know and that's why
it's so good
we take everything personal yeah i mean
like everybody does i mean it's like
that's pretty
like the barometer on how far you've got
in this growth game is how can how can
you
can you operate where you don't take
things personally because then it means
that you recognize that their actions
say more about the way they feel about
themselves than about you
um and it is
uh yeah that's that's a tough one isn't
it yeah
taking things personally is just like
normal and when i learned that simple
tool
um it it created the space for me to
just pause
to just stop
and breathe and i literally will reign
through through the process and it
actually goes pretty quick now so like
you said you we learn
new ways new tools to move through
so so we're just growing from what once
did service at times for protection and
and
expansion but there's new levels of it
as we're becoming
bringing more consciousness in and we're
opening more
in relationships in our lives and doing
that
how do how do we hold that space and do
it from our heart
and not from our head so the rain for me
gets me out of my head
it gets me into my heart space so i can
actually feel and speak from that place
and whether it's a difficult
conversation
or it's a conversation just full of love
and joy it still
is something that just keeps it
in truth another word of your yeah one
of your words of the year truth which is
the big one the many good ones
yeah yeah i feel like people
see like if somebody says to me which
has been said in
relationships or not as much friendships
but but it has happened or
in family where it's like you've changed
and i'm like
thanks because i've been trying you know
when people say you've changed and it's
supposed to be
um an insult yeah that's [ __ ]
because i mean you can change for the
worse
yeah sure you can you know we can think
of all those ways that you can change
for the worse you can become more
self-centered you can become more
materialistic you can become more
um you can you know start doing drugs or
alcohol and there's all kinds of ways to
to get worse but they're not really
growing they're they're those aren't
that's not the kind of like change in
growth that i'm talking about
it's when you've been working on
yourself and somebody says that you've
changed
i'm glad they've said that because i've
been freaking trying
um but there's this i think there's this
like opinion or thought that we're
supposed
that if you change it's wrong and you're
supposed to be the same person you were
as a kid and that's in fact like a
um an achievement if you don't change
um that you've remained yourself and i
think that that's a really
old and um uh
like i just think that's an old system
of thought
uh i think this day and age in you know
2019 we think about
um you know i feel like people are more
interested in growth and i sure am too
you know another thing i was thinking of
was with growth is that um you were
talking about feeling
and you do you feel it's annoying but
you feel
you feel a lot and i don't really feel
that deep but
probably from a young age you've been
probably if i'm
based on the stuff that you know i love
to learn about which is frequency and
vibration
um i would think that you probably are
more sensitive to frequency or more
sensitive to energy and the aura we put
off and
the general vibration that we put off so
i feel like uh i feel like you can do
things to raise your vibration and
there's like a whole chart on
you know the middle threshold and then
below it is the lower frequencies of
like
jealousy envy greed anger
suffering um all kinds of shame
all of those things fall in those lower
vibrational frequencies and then
once you cross over into the higher
vibrational frequencies
then what happened to me when i really
grew the most
i felt like was i was resonating at that
higher frequency
and i just literally didn't like being
in certain situations anymore i didn't
like i grew out of giving a [ __ ] about a
gossip magazine i grew
out of giving a [ __ ] about hanging out
with people to be nice i didn't want to
waste my energy in space
with people that didn't resonate with me
which is your word resonate
that just didn't resonate with my
frequency and so i feel like for me
the like the frequency thing is is a big
deal i feel like it's um
i feel like that's a lot of times the uh
invisible truth that lies
within all of us so you know i just did
a social post about
um friendships and how you know i
i truly believe that yes you can like
exit a friendship in a dramatic way if
you feel like it if you feel like
they're not in line in line with
you know who you are as a person anymore
and your values and maybe they've done
you wrong along the way
but if you just resonate at your new
frequency
as long as you can and consistently
that i do feel like people fade away
friends fall away relationships fade
away
jobs fade away your living circumstances
fade away your zip code fades away like
all of those things
like all those things are are are there
for
change when you change your frequency
because you're going to attract you're
going to
you're going to resonate with a new one
and i don't know where that is or who
that's going to be
or any of those things but but that to
me is like the effort
that's the that's the self-worth change
part where you don't even have to worry
about the rest it will figure itself out
like do you feel like that you feel like
you just stuff just changes even though
you've maybe not
asked for it so much or had to push
something it
just happens so this is a way that you
cannot feel like it's overwhelming like
man i
gotta get rid of them and yeah you're
right that just don't worry about it you
can also just like
stick stay in your truth stay focused on
what it is that you believe
and stay positive and just like
infiltrate your whole life from every
direction with positivity whether it be
whatever you i don't even watch the news
anymore i wake up in the morning and i
and i listen to podcasts watch youtube
videos listen to
east forest trevor hall and naco like i
mean i just zen out i write in my
journal
and like you have to create some new
activities sometimes to do that to raise
your frequency
yeah but but it's like it's possible
well when you embark on the journey of
opening up
that's when um our
vibrational field naturally becomes more
sensitive so when you're taking that
armor off
and you're also letting go of old ideas
of yourself
and you are in that vulnerable state you
feel a sensitivity
that is a total shift from
where you once were and naturally just
like you said we all have the
ability to feel at that level at the
energetic level
and that is why i chose
residence for the word of my year
because
it's all around energy and it's all
around what you feel and what do you
feel in your heart and what activates
you and what's giving you
time to say a pause and then i'll
reign through it and if i notice that
it's it doesn't feel an alignment
i actually can let go without judgment
without
um haste or any of that i can let go
more in a heart space and just move on
so any friendships that are shifting
just like you said it it is natural and
people
will feel our shift and so when you're
working from that space
they feel you differently and sometimes
the openness can be a little
intimidating or
or it just doesn't resonate with them
and so it's not it's not for people they
don't want to change
right and they're they're just in a
space of their own
because they're not ready yeah true and
that's ready
not ready to face their truths yeah so
it is a natural it's kind of like a
natural truth serum
when you choose to feel
from and what you resonate from and
vibrationally and really feel into that
and that's what i call my heart space
and our body will
kind of share with us what's coming
through too you're going to feel it in
all different ways i
um follow susie batis with
who is the inventor of poo pourri that i
love and she's speaking everybody loves
that
right exactly but she's incredible and
um i mean i instantly started resonating
yeah when i found her
talking about her for a while yeah i'm
really really drawn to her energy
and also her entrepreneurship so on a
multitude of ways because she's working
in business
from that space of vibrationally where
am i feeling a lot where am i feeling
activated she calls it alive as [ __ ]
like amaya feeling alive as [ __ ] right
now like is it
like she's just is it strong is it
powerful yeah i mean that's
when she speaks it's with intensity like
you
but it's coming from it's coming from
with softer it's nicer
no it's just different i mean that's you
and i both are intense but but we have
different intensities i have a very
soft deep intensity and it can be
intense for people
and you have a intense strength and
courage and fierceness that
totally enlivens me and gets me going
she does carry that and it's kind of a
blend of both of us
i feel like her energy is a blend of
both of us but
anyway she shared resonance
on one of her instagram posts i think in
january and i actually hadn't picked my
word of the year yet and that came
no that was december and that was it i
actually picked my word and i just knew
i mean it literally i felt it in my body
and i think that's because
of how sensitive i am and how much i
feel
it's honoring that and knowing that that
is a space
of truth and that it's okay to work from
that and it's also we each have our own
so it's authentic to who we are and if
we if we tap
into that and communicate from that
space with love
and compassion um empathy
uh it it shifts everything and so things
will fall off
and some things you will draw yeah new
friends you have some beautiful
the growth doesn't have to be ugly right
right and it's not that that's the i
don't think that's the kind of that's
that's not a good sign of the kind of
growth we're talking about the kind of
growth
is compassionate is loving is it
inclusive right i think that's the thing
too is like you want people to grow with
you right
and some people don't want to and some
people aren't ready
and sometimes that's also what happens
is that you have to
you have to understand that your new
life is going to cost you your old one
i read that on instagram back when i was
going through so many things
a couple of years ago and i'm like so
that's so [ __ ] true
like your old life is getting your new
life is going to cost your old one
and for me it was everything it was
relationship it was job it was living
i mean i i literally they all changed
within
um let's see i mean i like truth be told
i mean i retired
publicly at the track in homestead in 17
on
a saturday my last race was on sunday
i broke up with my boyfriend on monday
and then
you know within a week everything was
out of the house so like that's a lot of
[ __ ]
really close together and you know
sometimes
you just have to do what's right for you
and sometimes the growth
some people just don't want to come with
you and some people aren't ready
and sometimes you recognize that you
um you need something new and it can be
scary
oh yeah i mean i mean you've gone
through stuff that's been scary like
growth stuff and it's just reality yeah
but if you want to evolve
it's necessary you're exactly right
that's part of the evolution
and the expansion and
we also spoke on the transition
that process of growth yeah and
we need the vulnerability to grow
and then allowing space for the
transition and knowing that
there's parts where it's beautiful and
it feels good and i would be honest and
say there's a lot of parts from my
journey that
yeah were extremely challenging and
something that i
never thought would come through and and
not running in those cases for me and
doing the work and
feeling through it and then really
understanding
what was coming through yeah so let's
let's uh i feel like it
like it'd be really beneficial to cover
what it is exactly that we do for growth
so
here's what i do for growth when i wake
up in the morning i don't
this isn't like generalities this
specifics to me i wake up in the morning
i don't watch tv anymore i listen to
music i
journal i have started to try and
literally wake up
take a couple deep breaths and say thank
you i'm grateful for this day and try
and think of
three things that i want to do in the
day what i've realized is really
freaking hard to remember those three
because i'm half asleep
and they also talk about it being really
beneficial to
um to make changes in your life there
are brain states so there's beta which
is our go
go go go then there's our alpha which is
like the slowed down state there's theta
which is kind of your in and out
of almost sleep and then delta when
you're deep in sleep so if you can kind
of get into like the theta state
be in the theta state which is where you
are when you wake up
things are rooted a little deeper when
you when you
um call them to action so
maybe i'm i'm really hopeful that's
what's happening because i sometimes i'm
like shoot what was i
what was my goal today what were my
three goals today um but try and think
of three things that i want to do in the
day then of course i go downstairs and i
try and drink a big glass of water
before i chug multiple cups of coffee
and then i journal and i listen to good
music and i don't watch tv anymore
and then during the day i really try and
force myself to think positive
and give people the benefit of the doubt
and i eat really healthy i work out i
take time for myself
i always make sure that look being
selfish
is part of self-care i know selfish
sounds like a shitty word but
it's about self-care it's about taking
care of yourself to the point where
you can take care of others because i
don't think that if you don't if i don't
take good care of myself and i treat
myself like [ __ ] and i don't value
myself guess what that's exactly how i'm
going to treat everyone around me
so once you start to put yourself first
you start to put everyone else's
emotions first too
so i try and do that i try and make sure
that i do what it takes for me to
operate
from a place of like wellness positivity
uh
like i've given myself the time um and
some of that means quiet time too
so um i also think that maybe the final
final part that's important for growth
is that i feel like i found the most
growth when i spent time alone
and people have a really hard time being
alone but i am my own best friend
i have no problem with it and it's only
gotten easier over time i've always been
slightly in you know and i've always
been pretty independent but
i know how to run my day so i have
enjoyable good
experiences and i'm not lonely and i'm
not i'm not frustrated like i'm just
happy
and so spending time alone also helps
you helped me
really recognize what it is that i
actually liked what i was into
what was what was fun to me what was
stimulating to me
um and what was important to me so time
alone and i know it's hard if you don't
spend time alone i think that you're
probably the one that needs the most
spend the most time alone
very true it can be
scary to sit with yourself and your
feelings yeah um
and i'm right with you i love
my time alone yeah love it but i did
when i was oh nature i forgot about
nature oh
it's really important yeah
yeah okay so sorry go ahead yeah i mean
nature is literally one of the places
yeah you're a big human right you are
hiking you and i both feel
completely connected all the energies
around
us yeah are supportive
yeah and very very fluid so it creates a
very open state to feel whatever
wants to make its way in and whatever
wants to make its way out
and of course you're in pure beauty so
naturally you're just resonating and
vibrating
like i feel like i'm floating like i
think there is i feel like i've read
that there is a frequency in it in
nature that's a higher it's a higher
vibrational frequency
yeah so that's why you feel better yeah
part of it
definitely what else do you do so
i'm smiling just because and this is
what i love about us
and our friendship we're so connected in
this space and then the way we
we navigate our own personal growth and
our own personal journeys
are are different and yet the same
so for mine it's more fluid it's not
as it's not as
scheduled i wake up i mean i do
definitely it's i
have sophie girl my doctor who
is my sweet one that i love my husband
and um
for that we wake up we have coffee in
bed together
um we typically connect on i actually
will say how was your dreams what came
through for you dream wise
he'll check in with me whether one
remembers or one doesn't it's
just an interesting thing to kind of
talk about um
and we hold space around that then we
walk sophie we get out and we do a
walking meditation
um that's how it feels with music or
just walking in nature
just literally walking in nature so we
live up in carefree just north of
the city of phoenix and we're in the
mountains so
and you know like the more the more
nature i can get the better
yeah so we just moved up there and so
basically walking in the neighborhood
it's like you just hear the birds and
see the mountains and everything is
around you and you can do that anywhere
you can do that in the city also
but um walking and moving that energy
for me
after i've slept all night really helps
kind of flush out
and bring a new space it also helps with
connection with ben before
he heads off to work yeah yeah and um
and we come home
we'll practice some yoga sometimes i
mean that's really more of his
routine but i feel into it am i feeling
that i want to
you know join him in yoga that morning
we practice right at home doing that
and sometimes i do that and sometimes i
don't sometimes i just take time for
myself
because i feel like i want that and i i
got enough movement and energy flow
through the walk
and then and consciously it's just
always checking in throughout the day
i chicken with how i'm feeling so um
i'll notice myself when i get a little
bit restless and if i'm not in
in a full work schedule
kind of thinking i'm so creative and so
i kind of like
i'm floating around a lot and you float
a lot yeah i float a lot
and so i do need to get grounded you
totally ground me ben has great
grounding energy
and i have to ground i have to learn how
to ground myself down
so i find that and i do have tools that
do that and that does take
writing or simply having a conversation
with myself i mean it's like i check in
how am i feeling oh yeah i'm really
feeling like i want to do this or
or navigate in this way and so it's it's
a very fluid state and it shifts every
day
um but it's pretty consistent with the
wake up the time
connection the walk always yeah um i
walk every evening i end my night that
way
uh sometimes i'll pull cards i pay a lot
of attention
to the moon and what's coming in with
the new moon and the full moon that's
something i didn't used to do
but um i started about five years ago
and that's
that really resonates with me and i
check in and i
will journal around that time i have a
lot of information that comes through
around that um and
and yeah and i'm just kind of okay with
how it flows sometimes it's a full moon
and i don't do anything i just kind of
i look at her yeah and and i receive
from her and and it's just that
but i also know that our relationships
so the the people around me
definitely are vibrating at the
frequency
that i am if not higher so for you and
me
it's also friendships and the
relationships so that's very much a part
of my self-care and it's having someone
where i feel safe where i can be
vulnerable where i can share openly
communication
is huge obviously i don't have a problem
talking you know that
we neither of us do which is why they're
doing this yeah
and and that is medicine for me i mean
that provides growth it reflection
and having a friend that can reflect
back to me
my truth or when you notice that i'm
kind of retreating into my turtle shell
and you're like stays get out of your
comfort zone
get out of your comfort zone which you
i'm so grateful for that because i do
need that push so with the softness i
need the balance and i
and i need that so um and this is
something
you know we can stay friends then we can
stay friends i mean
it is we know that yeah i mean it's it's
eternal for us
um and i didn't start this process for
me
until it was about five years ago
almost six years ago when my husband and
i separated
and that was something that
was kind of the symptom it was it was
something that shook
enough where it's like wow how are we so
disconnected and what's going on here
and um i had a really good friend of
mine who's like stace i recommend i'd
already
been seeing another therapist before but
she's like i think
i have someone that i feel that would be
really in alignment and
um and i think you should go see this
person
this person and so uh so i was like oh i
have to go tell someone else my life
story for the last six years that i've
been doing
anyways um i felt into it there was a
resistance i didn't want to do it but i
did and it ended up being
one of the biggest shifts for me and
when i went to go in there to say hey
i don't even know what's going on she
just looked at me and said when did you
um lose your self-worth well that's when
you knew you had to grow
and i was like here's the growing girl
here's to growing thanks everybody for
listening to the pretty intense podcast
today i hope you enjoyed it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click
on the subscribe button